c'est un grand moment pour tracy et maya
sa fille de 18 ans elles viennent de
recevoir leurs bulletins de vote pour
participer à l'élection présidentielle
aux états unis pour ses deux yvelinoise
pas besoin d'attendre le 3 novembre
prochain elles vont voter par
correspondance
cette année a été absolument primordial
d'être sûr d'avoir de pouvoir voter à
temps pour les élections
du coup je ne serrerai d'illustrer en
ligne et aussi j'ai téléphoné à mes yeux
que tu es tu sûr que gta j'allais
recevoir un bulletin de vote pour new
york le bulletin est envoyé par la poste
par courrier par email par fax ou sur un
site internet
chacun des 50 états à son propre système
de vote par correspondance est mis et
son fils lucas vote en floride
ils ont le choix entre l'envoi dans une
enveloppe ou la possibilité de fax et
les documents aient voté pour la
première fois par fax
d'habitude je cochais mon bulletin et je
le mettais dans deux enveloppes mais
cette année il ya tellement de problèmes
avec la poste aux états unis que je n'ai
pas osé faire ça pour maya et lucas
c'est la première participation à une
élection présidentielle ils ont un
regard particulier sur leur pays
d'origine
je trouve que le pays va vers la
catastrophe
et j'en suis plus du tout vierge tout
cas tous les ans tout casser à sa
politique et ses actions à sa mentalité
est plus tout celle que je que je
partage les gens ne sont pas censés être
raciste nous 307 tout ce qui ce qui se
passe là en ce moment les la police qui
fait des bavures du côté de tracy et amy
ce scrutin est essentiel même s'il
rappelle le souvenir de la dernière
élection surprise en 2016 elle gît très
nerveuse en fait les gens me demandent
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez et je
préfère ne pas le dire il y a quelques
années je dis non je pense comme un
maire de et pas passer non et puis la
jeter non maintenant je n'ai plus rien
je croise les doigts comme tout le monde
je pense que cette une vote
existentielle celle à de futurs l'avenir
de la démocratie américaine est là cette
fois ci je pense qu'on pourrait basculer
dans l'autocratie
c'est absolument affolants pour voter de
l'étranger les citoyens américains
doivent s'inscrire sur ce site internet
plus de 6 millions de personnes sont
concernées dans le monde